there's someone that you see like messy
and stuff drinkin right down it pick up
the actually melt eight creams we do
absolute come on arm still every year
you got you got to drink the juice as
well that I'll eat the whole thing
you got drink a big big golf so it looks
like a big bowl agrees
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
do we have to pick they're actually
disgusting absolutely not
it's non don't know what that is
I'm definitely don't like that which
bits from Argentina well I've never seen
Lima life and guessing it's that smells
like caramel that's actually not that
bad that go great on some pancakes even
[Music]
open why
might need a bucket after this one
Kobe's sick but things do Emily it's
disgusting that should be sold
I'm a bit more let's get that way in
fairness that is that thank you
Oh a little brew that's perfect as well
no these milk oh is it like green tea it
is the one that you see like missing
stuff them right down it definitely
England yeah well these yeah that's it
pinatas what does that mean what's in it
I'm sticking to my roots about Marmite
you've said that about the team yeah
very nice only be near it worse worse
than what it is yes that's awfully well
yeah sassy girl
[Applause]
I'm really ready yeah
[Music]